all right well I'm going to do a few
things today first I'll talk a little
bit about myself you know especially for
some of the students here since I was at
Stanford student you know you can you
can find out you know what what life is
life after you leave talk a little bit
about microsoft research and the
organization that we built in sort of
why we do basic research at microsoft
when a lot of other companies don't seem
to and and then talk a bit about you
know how some of the the innovations
that are happening right now you know I
that I think are really really exciting
are really beginning to change the way
we think about doing computing and the
things that we do with computing so
that's kind of my plan let me tell you a
little bit about myself so I was a
undergraduate here at Stanford from 1972
1974 so that was a few years ago and the
interestingly enough I was a comparative
literature major and a math major now
there wasn't a computer science
undergraduate degree back in those days
I did take all the computer science
courses I could but and of course I went
on to graduate school in computer
science but but why I was here I was
kind of this weird thing between
humanities and and mathematics which is
made for serving an interesting career I
think of going o going going on from
there I did my graduate work at the
University of Rochester and we had the
privilege really there of being the
first place outside of Xerox to actually
have access to the Xerox Alto so that's
really where I got to get my you know
hands really dirty you know working with
what at the time was was over the
premier computing platform if you really
wanted to experiment with personal
computing and and that was that was a
lot of fun why was this graduate student
I got a chance to build one of the very
first network computer games it's
something called Alto Trek that amusing
enough sleep keeps coming back into my
life and when form of the other and in
fact many years later I actually took
that Alta Trek game from the 1970s
updated it and turned it into a very
different but
but slightly related game for Microsoft
that was Microsoft's first online only
game that we ship which is called
allegiance and if you feel like it you
can still actually go out on the
internet and play allegiance there's a
group of hardy people who who still play
it that I think its allegiance org or
something like that that you have to go
to to get access to it so so I had a
chance to do a lot of things back then
that I you wouldn't otherwise be able to
do went to Carnegie Mellon did my my you
know stint as a professor there for
about 12 years and why was very
developed something called the mock
operating system which interestingly
enough has been calm kind of influential
in a lot of different places it became
the basis for the next step system that
that Steve Jobs used in the late 1980s
it became then the basis for the mac OS
that exists today so my graduate student
I be today nyan went to next and
eventually to apple and use the mock
operating system as a basis for for the
development of Mac OS and eventually iOS
so chances are good you're running some
lines of my code if you're using any of
those products but also if you're using
versions of UNIX a a number of versions
of eunuchs were based on the mock
operating system including digital's
unix the open software foundation's unix
compacts unix and HPS of 264 unix so
those are all based on mock in fact mock
was the first 64-bit version of unix
that became available and then if you're
using microsoft products you're probably
using my code too because you know a lot
of the work that that we've done since
I've come to Microsoft is embedded in
various versions of Windows and some of
our other products including the xbox so
you have a chance to take advantage of
something I did you know once some line
of code during that period of time I
think during the course of my career
I've implemented something like six
hundred thousand lines of code quite a
few of them are still running somewhere
so so it's been an interesting you know
way to to get into a career now and it's
kind of weird for a hacker
type person to sort of have the career I
had so I went to Microsoft in 1991 and
and there's a little bit of a story
associated with that so I'll tell it
because I think it's an interesting part
of the question of you know what why
does Microsoft do basic research and
what what is the reason why microsoft
research exists so if you go back to
nineteen ninety i was still carnegie
mellon at that time a gentleman named
Nathan Myhrvold wrote a memo to
Microsoft board of directors and in that
memo he said you know we really need a
basic research organization it was a
nice interesting memo I still have a
copy of it somewhere and what was
remarkable is that he was trying to
convince a really small company to
invest in long-term basic research
Microsoft was just that year hitting
about a billion dollars in in revenue
not in profits now that's a pretty small
company to be thinking about investing
in long-term basic research but i think
it's a it's a it's a statement about the
way the company thought then and thinks
today that it believed that it was
important to do that so they went around
trying to figure out you know what kind
of a person they wanted to run this
thing and wound up with me you know it's
interesting if you read his memo
Nathan's memo it talks about having some
old guy that would be kind of the the
sage figurehead you know for the
organization and some some really
energetic young person that was actually
going to be you know making everything
happen I think they settle on me and
I've been able to do the job long enough
that I started out young and I now have
become old so I've accomplished both
both both goals that I think existed in
that memo I guess I should also mention
because i said that i started microsoft
research in 1991 been running it since
then that among other things makes me
the the microsoft executive has been
doing the same job for the longest time
i'm not sure exactly what that says
about me
it could say that I only really know how
to do one thing although I've done quite
a few things my life so it doesn't quite
say that it certainly says that I
started young enough to be able to make
it for that long emmanuel priority was
started IBM research i think he lasted
about 15 years before he finally had to
retire so so i had the advantage of just
starting young when i went to microsoft
and actually i was here at Stanford in
1992 presenting a series of slides on
Microsoft Research and an older version
of this slide was one that I used and in
fact these words are the ones that I
used in that slide back in 1992 it
wasn't in this auditorium but it was
someplace on campus and this has been
the mission statement that I've had for
the entire time you know I've been at
Microsoft Research and it's always
worked really well for us the mission
statement is is here the idea that that
I had is that you know our primary goal
would be the same goal that I had when I
was at Carnegie Mellon and the Carnegie
Mellon computer science department had
which was expanding the state of the art
and nothing about this it's really
anything to do with Microsoft right it
says that if we're going to work in an
area if we're going to do basic research
we're going to do the best that we
possibly can and we're going to push the
state of the art in the areas that we're
working and it really doesn't matter you
know what's going on in Microsoft I mean
if we're doing it we should we should be
pushing the state of the art now if if
this works I mean if you have great
ideas and then something happens and it
turns out that something actually worked
it looks like it's potentially usable in
some product then we really try to do
this as well which is move as quickly as
possible from the research side of
things into products and that's always a
the time frame for that is is is not you
know something is
particularly fixed i think the shortest
period from invention to being on a
shelf is about six weeks that was
something that i did you know sometimes
it takes 15 years you know you don't
really know because you don't know about
the circumstances I'll explain that a
little bit more in a moment but the key
thing is you work really hard to make
this happen but you don't try to have
this influence the first part right in
some sense you don't want to buy us that
front end of the innovation pipeline now
I'll explain a little bit more about
what I mean in a minute ultimately the
goal here is this which is in it
although the word microsoft appears here
it's not really just about microsoft the
goal is just to make sure that in some
sense the field of computer science has
a future right we need to keep
innovating we need to keep changing we
need to keep moving forward if we as a
group are going to have influence on the
future I mean there are many other
fields and technologies that stopped
innovating or stopped having that level
of impact at some point of time we need
to keep doing that and certainly for a
company in the technology business if
you don't do this you just don't the
future so when I went to start bikes off
research basically my goal was you know
take what I was familiar with at
Carnegie Mellon in the in the 1980s MIT
and and put that inside of a company
like Microsoft and so that's really the
structure that we have and in some ways
I think arguably you could say that
microsoft research today is probably a
little bit more like Carnegie Mellon's
computer science department in the mid
1980s than Carnegie Mellon is today
because it just changes in the way
government financing works and in a
bunch of other factors that have come in
the meantime so this is basically the
structure you'll be a very sort of
university style structure you know our
our technical levels for employees
everything everything is really based
around the notion of university titles
and university notions of how things
work we have very open research
environment we aggressively publish and
Microsoft
research is the number one publisher of
basic research in the field of computer
science so if you look at all the papers
being published today we publish more
than anybody else by quite a bit and you
know we continue to do that and a lot of
our if you look at a lot of conferences
like siggraph the this coming siggraph
for example just our research lab in
beijing just one little piece of
microsoft research will have ten percent
of the papers that say graph this year
right so that's kind of a statement
about the the amount of work that we do
publish and the reason we think
peer-reviewed publication is important
is because it's a quality bar it really
forces everybody to compete
intellectually in an open environment
and that makes sure that we achieve that
first part of the mission statement
which is that we really are pushing for
the state of the art and then we're not
deceiving ourselves into thinking that
that's what we're doing I mean I think
it's very easy for a a closed research
environment to start over time deceiving
itself into thinking it's it's doing
something when it isn't really out the
state of the art it isn't really
competing with other people we have lots
of visitors I mean it's a huge number a
huge number of interns we run probably I
mean I don't know the numbers for every
other company but I'd say there's a good
chance we run the largest PhD internship
program certainly in the field of
technology microsoft research worldwide
has over a thousand PhD interns working
each year and you know so roughly you
can sort of figure yeah we prep the
equivalent of say you know 350 or so you
know graduate student years you know
work full time working in Microsoft
Research every year so over a thousand
individual interns just when the United
States it's about 450 PhD interns and
that's an approximation because I don't
know quite what it's going to turn out
to be this year I know the Puget Sound
area were now limited by housing
availability of housing which has gotten
much tighter as the economy's come back
so so we have a huge number of interns
we've lots of visitors
we have strong ties to university and
and we've devoted a lot of our of the
money that I manage over the years to
universities we fund faculty fellowships
graduate student fellowships lots of
research programs at a number of
different institutions and really
continue to view that as an important
part of what we do so this is what you
know we I started as employee number one
back in September one of 1991 this is
what Microsoft Research looks like today
and you know our single biggest lab is
still here in redmond we have a fairly
large group here in Silicon Valley about
85 researchers here PhD researchers
station Q is in Santa Barbara that's our
quantum computing group they do
topological quantum computing pretty
exciting work we now have a group in New
York that we opened up this last last
summer and a group in New England so
that sort represents the United States
outside the US if Cambridge which was
our second lab first live outside the
United States second major lab and
they're about the third largest we have
Microsoft Research Asia which by the way
is located here i'm not sure why the
dots in the wrong place but i think
they're just trying to take over we joke
internally as to why it's called
Microsoft Research Asia and not just
China but I think they have they have
plans anyway they they're actually the
second largest group in Microsoft
Research now they're the atls are
advanced technology labs so these have
PhDs in them but they're primarily
focused on advanced development they're
not part of the core research
organization we have an atl in europe
currently we're in aachen germany but
it's moving to munich so by this by
sometime this summer it'll be a munich
we have group in israel and a group in
cairo and we've announced that we're
opening a group in rio probably later
this year or early next year we have an
announced a date and frankly i don't
even know so that's but that served with
the stay of the organization of a group
in bangalore but our largest groups are
redmond beijing and cambridge us is
about half and everybody else is about
how
so it's about 5050 inside and outside
the United States so Kenny back to
something I was talking about earlier
there's this question ok so not that
many companies these days it seemed to
be interested investing in in long-term
basic research at least in the
technology field and you know obviously
Microsoft's just decided a long time ago
to do that we've been very consistent in
doing it for a long period of time so
one has to ask the question sort of you
know why I mean so what first off why
are we doing it and why is it that other
people don't seem to I mean what is it
that that is has in some sense caused
people to retrench from making those
kinds of investments in a number of
other companies well to some extent it's
a little bit about I think that the
reason comes back to to the reasons why
one would think about investing in basic
research versus why you probably really
should so the main reasons when you talk
to people when they say you know I I
think I know why I should invest in
basic research org or sometimes they'll
simply say I think I know why I should
hire some PhDs right and the first thing
they'll say as well you know that would
be a great source for intellectual
property and technology and that's true
I mean a good well-run research
organization whether it's in Microsoft
or Stanford or Carnegie Mellon or
Berkeley you do generate a lot of
intellectual property you create a lot
of technology so that's true and if you
look at microsoft's patent portfolio for
example about twenty-five percent of the
patents come out of microsoft research
and those are really arguably the most
fundamental part and you know for a
number of years the I Tripoli's rated
Microsoft's patent portfolio as the most
scientifically strong in the technology
field and a lot of it comes out of these
kinds of patents because they're really
based on sort of state-of-the-art
research that we're doing so that's a no
that's a reason it's certainly you know
a good reason in a sense that it's
something generating that you get a
value but I would kind of argue that
that's that's not the reason you should
do it it's
great byproduct of having a great
research organization you can think of
it as prot as you know problem solving
group right got a bunch of PhDs you know
PhDs are trained to solve problems right
I love solving problems irie actually I
really enjoy people come to me the
problem I just love working on it you
know a lot of our researchers are like
that they just love have people coming
and bringing the problems you know
that's what we're trying to do we've
been doing it for a good part of our
lives and and there's a real value to
corporation and doing that you can say
okay well research group is a great
early warning system you get to see all
this new technology you see what's going
on in labs in various other places you
work with universities you know so you
get to see what the future looks like
well don't exactly you don't exactly see
what the future is like you see what the
future of technology may be like you
don't get to see what society
necessarily is going to do with the
technology but in any case it is a great
place you know you can you know tell the
product groups you know there's a
technology on the horizon there's a good
chance it's going to be important you
need at least pay attention to it or be
thoughtful about it as you plan out you
know more than one or two releases in
the future but I would argue these are
all I products these are things that you
get because you have a basic research
organization there are certainly things
that people value you could argue they
pay the bills you know on a on an
ongoing basis for for doing research if
you talk to you know people in
government that fund research here at
Stanford those are the kinds of things
they'll talk about you know in terms of
the you know the country in the United
States but the real reason I think you
you invest in basic research is actually
this its agility or maybe a different
word to use as survival right so if you
go back to you know Vannevar Bush's
writings you know it one of the people
helped to do set in motion the creation
of the national science foundation you
know he talks about wanting to make sure
that the country invest in basic
research so that in some sense it could
survive we just come through
or technology and ideas were an
important part of winning that war and
in his mind he serves oh what if we have
another war what if we have a terrible
disease what if there's a famine you
know we want to make sure that we have
this or treasure chest of ideas and
technology but more importantly of
people that will will think us out of it
right that will that will help get us
out of whatever that terrible situation
is going to be in and allow the country
to survive the same argument really
applies to a company which is you're
constantly certainly in the technology
field a company is constantly being
attacked not just by other companies you
have competitors so you have new
competitors all the time their new
technologies but they're also constantly
changing business conditions right the
world keeps changing and you have to
keep adapting and you really need that
reservoir of ideas and technologies but
more importantly of people that allow
you as an organization to survive and in
some sense it's really the the
unexpected that is the reason you do
have a basic research organization and
if you look back on Microsoft's
competitors you know back in 1990 1991
right when Mike self research got
started the companies that were like us
back then some of them larger than I was
back then they're gone right they just
disappeared they didn't invest in basic
research they didn't they didn't really
put a lot of energy into that kind of
future thinking and and something in
each case something happened right and
you don't know what's going to happen
something happens and then you don't
know you if you if you're not in some
sense making certain kinds of
investments you may not be able to dig
out now you may not be able to take out
anyway but at least you have a fighting
chance let me give you an interesting
historical example and
I you know I asked the forbearance of
the students in the audience because
this is a example from the early 1990s
so for some of you might might have been
a long time ago so back in 1992
microsoft research was really small we
have maybe 10 or 15 people and one of
our researchers working with some of the
other people came up with an idea for a
technology basically came up with an
idea for reducing the working set size
of 32-bit programs and it was a really
good idea may basically he figured out
how you could rearrange the bytes in the
program in such a way that at runtime
the program would take up about half as
much physical memory as it would
otherwise take up now this was pretty
cool it with all mouth right you know
but we thought was pretty cool and we we
thought hey this would be one of the
first major things we could get the
product groups interested in remember we
were just started and I can remember
sitting in meetings with our our product
teams back then the meeting so every
single meeting with every product group
pretty much went like this so we'd sit
down that we explain the technology
which show how we could reduce the
working set size and everybody with nod
and they'd asked some good questions who
the really smart people and and at the
end they would look at us and they would
say you you guys you guys are just
really smart okay we didn't even know
those letters were in the Greek alphabet
okay you guys are just like amazingly
smart but we don't have 32-bit code it's
1992 we have 16 bit code all right we
know we're going to have 32 the code
right everybody knew is on the horizon
but they said you know Moore's Law is
going to mean that we'll have lots of
memory so by the time we need the extra
memory you know I best will have it you
know and it'll be all cheap and it'll be
great but a funny thing happened on the
way to 1995
and that you can see it in these price
charts for 4d Rams the price memory
didn't actually go down it actually went
up a little bit and so what was
happening there's some issues in Asia
and some trade issues and plants that
were having problems and various other
reasons why it all happened but none of
that really matters that the problem was
you get to 1995 you know right here and
in what's happening now is that you know
price of DRAM doesn't really doesn't
really go down and guess what all of our
product coops now have 32-bit code
they're ready to ship office 95 and
windows 95 the two biggest products that
were going to make the future of
microsoft and and unfortunately people's
computers didn't have any more memory
than they did in 1992 and so while you
know we had this wonderful new 32-bit
operating systems in office products the
computers really couldn't run them you
know they were still at those days it
was four and eight megabytes of memory
is what a typical corporate pc had
that's megabytes not gigabytes ok so the
world was a little different back then
and what was what was a problem for us
was hey we were ready to ship this code
and you know it wasn't gonna fit the
good news is that we in the research
group we'd actually continue to work on
that technology that I talked about from
1992 we'd actually find it quite a bit
we made it so that it worked well well
within Microsoft's development process
and development stock so when they hit
the wall they could come to us was that
part of like kidding hitting the wall
when they hit the wall they could come
to us and and we have the solution for
them right so so they were able to ship
office 95 windows 95 in 1995 and that
had a huge huge impact on the company
there were two ways in which that impact
occurred the first was we made several
hundred million dollars that we wouldn't
otherwise have made now we were still a
small enough company you know and it was
95 when several hundred million dollars
was with Stillman you know real money ok
you know so you could take your family
to see a 3d movie right with several
well they didn't have 3d movies but you
could just you could take your family to
a movie for a few hundred million
dollars right you if you saw it on the
ground you would pick it up all right
now today not it's not super clear you
know especially in Silicon Valley with
all the stuff going on billions and
billions it's not clear anybody really
cares but back then it was a lot of
money but way more important than the
money because you know money comes the
money goes right way more important than
the money was the strategic value
because our main competitors Lotus and
we're perfect did not have this
technology right so they did not have
the ability to ship their 32-bit
products and yeah without basically just
I mean their stuff food just wouldn't
have run so it was almost a year before
they wound up shipping and more to the
point even when they did they were fat
and slow you know compared to what we
were shipping the impact of that
strategically on the future of Microsoft
was just astronomical right there's no
monetary value you can really assigned
to that because that's the difference
between between surviving and not
surviving you know if you talk to ray
ozzie who have talked to many times
since he eventually came to work at
Microsoft he was the one of the founders
of Lotus he said hey you know that just
killed us right we they knew we had
something they didn't know how it worked
they didn't know what did exactly except
that they knew that you know we were
able to run our code and they couldn't
you know and that's the that's what a
basic research group does and you can't
go out and buy that technology right
because if somebody had it outside the
company then everybody would know it was
there right this was something that was
there was a solution to a critical
problem that was inside ready to go when
the company actually needed it yes
eventually it wasn't published at the
time we did it because it was you know
we were working with the product teams
but it was eventually published
if you look today you know so I talked
about the mission statement I said look
you know first is we move the state of
the art forward and we're doing that
we're publishing you more than anybody
else's right now but we are working
really hard yet technologies into our
product this is just a list of things
that that have come out of microsoft
research that have where our
technologies have gone into our products
since fall right and this isn't a
complete list right so there's a huge
impact today in terms of things that are
going in and what's interesting in a way
yeah yeah let me just wait on that one
what's interesting in a way here is that
you know it's not like we really talked
about this a lot right our product
groups don't go out and say hey you know
we've got this and that because we comes
from a research group that's really not
their goal there goes to build their
stuff in the sell the product and
they're doing a great job of doing it
and you know in all we're doing in some
sense is giving them sort of the pieces
of you know some part of a puzzle that
they have to do the rest of and to
really make these things work so it's an
important part of what goes on let me
give you a specific example of a more
recent technology transfer still from a
few years ago to give you a sense of how
things go sometimes and where you know
house are your fundamental research then
can set you'll be translated into
product activity so this is actually a
picture from 2009 June of 2009 and that
was when are our xbox group you know
first talked about what they called it
the time project natal you would know it
now as as Microsoft Kinect and they they
showed a little bit of it on stage at
that point now behind the scenes what
was oh the obligatory if you've never
seen connect that's what it looks like
okay the chance you've never seen
connect too small so I'm just keep I'm
going to keep going on for their but but
the key thing it actually it's it's
it's worth making a comment here the key
thing about connect that was really
exciting is that is that you move and
the computer actually can tell you're
moving right and the characters on the
screen can mimic your body and you know
it was interesting because we were on
the beta for this when it eventually got
done and I could tell was going to be
super successful when my kids which
four years ago they would have
been eight and ten when they were
playing with this and they were having
more fun after they won jumping up and
down having their character jump up and
down with them and celebrating then they
had playing the game right they had
completely lost themselves in the into
this virtual world because the character
on the screen mimicked what they did and
and they made that they made that that
connection and that was really what was
cool about it now the problem with
Kinect there were two elements of
Connect right the first is the 3d camera
and for those of you don't know how the
kinect actually works there's a a an ir
a pattern that is sent out and then a
camera that scans and basically yo does
the 3d reconstruction based on on the
the pattern that's that scanned out
that's very very simple version of what
goes on the reason use IR by the ways
because you don't know what lights going
to be in the room you can't depend on
lighting right so you need you need to
be able to do it matter what the
lighting looks like now people been
playing with three cameras and so forth
for a long time actually my most people
don't know this but my PhD thesis was in
3d motion 3d 3d image reconstruction for
motion images so so even I had some
experience doing it the problem with
trying to do actual tracking in a 3d
environment like that with us with a
three-dimensional camera
is that you lose stuff really easily
plus the the Kinect you know it's a
relatively low resolution in terms of
depth you know it's reasonable but it's
relatively low resolution so there's a
lot of confuse ability you know and if
you move you move around you put your
arm behind your back you step next to a
table your dog jumps on you you know
there's some your brother said you know
comes up next to you but it's really
easy to lose track of what's going on in
the scene and in traditional me this has
always been this toric problem with with
with computer vision tracking right is
that your tracking tracking tracking and
then suddenly something is obscured or
something goes wrong you lose it and now
you have to reacquire and recompute
everything and it's not particularly
easy to do and it generally generates a
lot of errors which one of the reasons
why you know people never really tried
you know putting a 3d camera in a room
with children and dogs and and
grandparents and so forth and furniture
before right because it's just nobody
had ever thought about that I even
beginning to do that environment that
that's that confusable so the prog group
came to to us actually came to me and
they said look we have some technology
but you know it's not really working
well enough to actually ship you know
there's too much confuse ability we lose
people you know and we need something
that's really reliable in these very
complex environments and so that was
where we we basically you know paired up
that team with a group of our computer
vision researchers and you know and
that's where connect really started to
work because what what our team did
actually Jamie chaton in our research
lab in in Cambridge England was one of
the key ones working on this what they
did is I realized that this wasn't
really a tracking problem it wasn't it
was a sort of machine learning object
identification problem and they built a
machine learning system that could
recognize the different parts of the
body with relatively high probability
right so it was based on a decision
forest technique that's all published in
siggraph you can go find out all
details about how the how the code
actually worked but what was exciting
about it was if you paired that with
with the tracking capabilities of the
camera suddenly had something that was
extremely reliable in a lot of settings
and that really gave us the ability to
ship you know what was really the first
you know real-time 3d computer vision
system for the home right that anyone's
ever seen and it really changed it was
cool about connect was it change not
just the you know it wasn't just a great
product I mean we solve like 10 million
units in 60 days so that's a really good
product we think now is over 30 million
in the attached rate on connects is
actually on Xboxes it's extremely high
now but it did more than that it
actually changed the way people in the
computer vision community thought about
doing yo computer vision it changed the
way people thought about the research
and there's this huge you know upsurge
of of new research being done in an area
that frankly had stopped having a lot of
interesting work going on you know so so
I think that wasn't to me at least that
was even more exciting than the product
although the product was pretty exciting
to let me give you another example
that's really recent of a sort of
fundamental computer science technology
that's now having a pretty interesting
impact in in a product so there's a new
feature in office 2013 so if you have a
chance to try it I would recommend it
it's a lot of fun basically it's in
Excel it's called flash fill and the
idea behind flash fill let me see
actually I'm going to run the video and
then I'll explain a little bit more and
I don't is there any way to get sound on
this or not beyond the problem
all right it's okay i can just describe
what's going on I've done the best I can
so let me just describe what's going on
here so here you are at excel okay now
he's taking it away but basically the
idea is you have you have some column of
material let me just actually go back
here and just pause it there so I can
talk about it so you have some column
right these are say social security
numbers and which you really want is you
want to put the dashes in because you
really kind of like the way it looks
with Dow Jones now you all right I guess
I didn't pause it now eh there we go now
it's cost so up now you can do this in
excel macros right but it's it's not
that the most trivial thing in the world
for a user to be able to do what you'd
like to do is effectively say hey you
know and you can do perl scripts i mean
there's a lot of ways to do something
like this right but what you really want
to say look I've got stuff like this I
went to have stuff that looks like that
right and see if I can skip forward to a
place where it's actually I'm just going
to have trouble with this but maybe
you'll finish up the all right let's see
if you actually finish this is up yeah
so what happens is you click a button
and the the whole thing turns out
exactly what you expected it to right so
what's happening under in flash fill
will do this with with pretty
complicated is transformations basically
the idea is you have a bunch of stuff
you want to change it you know you want
your reverse first name and last name
you want to capitalize you know certain
things you want to you know put
parentheses around it you want whatever
I mean there's a lot of different kinds
of transformations some of them very
complicated you can do math with this as
well right you want to you change some
of the fields and add them together
manipulate them flash fill will do that
what's happening is is this is really in
advance and automated programming
so what's happening on so going back to
the around 2000 you know Mike's Bikes
off research has been pioneering work in
in a program analysis for for quite some
time you know our first use of heavy use
of program analysis technology was in
windows XP actually and we've been
advent you know advancing it since then
some of you may be familiar with a
system called slam that it was basically
designed to do proof of properties of
device drivers originally for Windows
Vista and now in our most recent
products so this thing called the static
driver verifier in Windows and basically
that's a that's a program proof
technology and we extensively use
program proof technologies now in our
products what's interesting is you can
the guys realize you can run the program
proof technology backwards an
effectively write code with a set of
examples and you know there's a bit more
to it than what I just said but the key
insight was this notion that you know we
could take what we've learned from
program proof to do automatic program
generation the currently the technology
is capable of doing you know programs of
modest size sort of on the order of 20
or 30 steps but what's interesting is
the steps can be a more or less
arbitrary complexity so you can actually
do some really interesting and fairly
complex things as long as you have
descriptions of the operators that are
mathematical and so what's effectively
happening is is when you give in flash
fill you give a series of maybe one or
two occasionally three examples what
it's doing is it's taking the outputs
it's like taking the inputs looking at
the outputs and generating the optimal
program in this case in excel macros
that would generate the output from the
input and it works remarkably well i
mean i can recommend you play with it so
it's it's you know you can play with it
either in the you know in you know p
state office 365 environment and it's
it's very fun the other the interesting
part of it is that you know it's not
always going to be right you may not
have specified everything right so you
know
let's say you know I was I was trying to
put in parentheses but there there was
maybe there was an entry that already
had some parentheses you know if you see
an error you can correct it rerun now
uses that example along with the others
and it will again generate program and
usually after maybe one iteration if you
if it makes mistake at all typically one
iteration it fixes it this is a really
cool feature but what's more interesting
in a way to me is that you know this is
one of the first real examples of using
automated programming automatic program
a generation you know in a real setting
and what's exciting about this is that
we're now leveraging this technology in
more and more areas not just within our
products but within our research
organizations because there's a lot of
places where where the ability to be
able to take sets of examples and
automatically generate code to to
implement them can be used in
conjunction with other things for
example in conjunction with machine
learning so that's really very exciting
as the video didn't have any in the
audio I'm not going to go into it an
area where you know everybody talks
about these days is that is is this
whole issue of big data and data
sciences and everything is very
data-oriented now and there's another
video here and it's also got worried so
I'm not good to go through it but we're
using it in all sorts of different ways
I think one of the interesting things is
is how can we as a computer science
community help scientists and people in
other fields using these kinds of
technologies so one of the things that
we've done is something that's called
fetch climate you can use this it works
with any web browser it's you go to
fetch climate org yo I don't know if
actually there is a fetch climate that
work look at fetch climate under
research at microsoft.com website but
basically the idea is to give to create
an environment at which we can collect
environmental data from many different
data sources on the web that are free
data sources we get them into
windows azure and then we make them
available to scientists to do
interesting kinds of analysis on it so
for example one of the first things we
did was to work with sort of really
basic climate data you know temperature
winds air pressure all those kinds of
things and of course there's many
different data sources and the data
sources don't agree and so one of the
things too that we built into the system
is the ability to do automatics or
confidence assessment of the data so
that you can give scientists not just
data points but you can give them you
know what level of confidence exists in
the data that they're working with and
that can be part of their part of their
environment I'm not going to show that
you can also use this in areas like
health care so we've been working with a
number of hospitals in terms of you know
giving them tools that are predictive in
one form of the other so this is some
work that Eric Horvitz is done working
with the amalga product it was
originally part of Microsoft now there's
a joint venture with GE that has the
amalga product in it but the idea was to
be able to predict you know when
patients were likely to return within 30
days at the point that they were being
discharged and not just to predict that
because by itself that's not super
helpful for the doctor but actually to
give the doctor effective ways of
mitigating that you know cost-effective
ways of mitigating it and reducing that
probability so what they did was not
just look at all the factors that went
into the chance of the patient would
come back within 30 days so you know
they think because it was within the
context of amalgam alga collects a huge
amount of data within the hospital so
you would take into account things like
the the number of you know what room
numbers people were in what what nurses
and doctors saw them what medications
they were taking huge amount of data
about the patient was being taken into
account as part of this this analysis
but in
dition part of the system was to look at
the possible mitigations for example you
know bring them back in a few days for
four in an office visit have a nurse
call them up you know you know bring
them in for a real will check up I mean
there are lots of different things that
you could imagine doing that would
reduce the chance that a patient would
come back what you needed to do is be
able to determine which mitigation
strategies were cost-effective for this
particular patient in reducing the
chance that they would not return
because if you basically if you just
applied one of these mitigation
strategies they're all you'll cost money
and on average that wouldn't be cost
effective to just apply them you know to
the entire group you wanted to know
which mech which technique was going to
be effective for which patient and to be
able to do that so so that was actually
a very interesting use of of again
computer science technology machine
learning technology but in this case to
help address a medical issue in
hospitals and we work with Mass General
and some other organizations to deploy
that it's now part of a product another
area we for many years now we've been
putting energy into is HIV vaccine
design the idea here is to well the
original idea was actually very very
simple which is to say you know yo HIV
the genome serve looks like a string
great computer science we know we know
how to deal with strings and we know how
to manipulate strings and the question
then is you know the the problem with
HIV is that you're not just solving for
a particular version of the virus but
the virus is constantly mutating so it's
like spam right so if you think of what
spam looks like you know they're
spammers are constantly changing the the
content of spam to try to find a way
around the spam filters well HIV isn't
exactly conscious but it since it's
constantly mutating the mutations find
ways around the body's defenses and so
the idea was to say how could we use
machine learning
techniques to to effectively go after
whatever the weakest link is in the
virus I mean so so just as in the case
of spam so Microsoft did the first
machine learning-based spam detector
back in the 90s and the idea behind that
spam detector wasn't to just identify
spam it was to identify things that
would allow spammers to make money
because if you could remove the economic
value from spam it reduced the chances
that spammers would really care about
changing it and you would be trying to
break that cycle well here with the idea
is the same which is to try to identify
what parts of the virus are really
important for the virus to continue to
be effective in reproducing itself and
allowing itself to continue to infect
other patients or other parts of the
body and if you could go after that if
you think of that as the cash you know
for the HIV virus then again the goal
was to try to be able to do that so
great deal of progress has been made
there and again I've got a video to talk
about it but I'm not going to be able to
know why the sound just doesn't work
well okay supposedly this is on buzz all
right well I'm not going to be able to
go through this and show it I'm afraid
but yeah we need to find a solution to
this one though so does this does this
work because if this works I can use
this to funnel this out okay there we go
all right let's see if we can make this
is an interesting solution to the
problem
david Eckerman a microsoft vaccine for
HIV folks at harvard on switch is that
coming out its instantaneous challenges
and making a vaccine that HIV mutates
very rapidly about million times faster
than humans setting how HIV mutates in a
person using learning and high
performance computing good piece of news
is that we've discovered HIV does not
mutated random rather it's quite
susceptible to our immune system to
attack one bad piece of news is that we
now believe that fits of HIV service
decoys bring the immune system to waste
its resources on fruitless attacks in
fact we think these decoys may be
responsible for the recent failure of
the earth vaccine were vaccinated
individuals we're susceptible to getting
HIV it's possible that the Merck vaccine
contains some of the same decoys found
in HIV and thus wknd the immune systems
of those who were vaccinated we're in
the process of testing this hypothesis
with researchers at the hutch who
oversaw the vaccine trial if true it
should shift the focus of vaccine design
to the search for decoys to exclude I'm
humbled by the impact that this work is
having on the research it's quite an
exciting time and analyzed the factors
involved in epitope stability for that
we performed a computational analysis
with the help of david yurman from
microsoft wizard I'd like to thank
everyone in Bruce Walker's up here in
Boston specialty Sabrina David hecker
Minh and his colleagues at Microsoft
Research who did the majority developing
the disability identity nice mutations
finally I'd like to acknowledge all of
my colors and collaborators on this
study especially my brother chanson
david hagerman and jonathan carlson
without whom so pretty much wouldn't be
possible
so you get the point I you know I don't
think when i started microsoft research
i was really thinking that we would
somehow be working on you know vaccine
design but what's been interesting about
this is that you could serve again for
you some of this goes back to my first
part of my my mission statement you know
we're going to do work in an area you
know we're we're going to carry it
forward and we're going to we're going
to have an impact but the but the
interesting part of this it isn't is it
just valuable for the vaccine world a
lot of the techniques that David's Group
has developed for doing really fast
machine learning on certain kinds of
data has actually now turned out to be
extremely valuable in work that we're
doing you know within our prior groups
because increasingly now machine
learning is a key part of almost any
product that Microsoft is doing so yep
yeah it was it's an interesting thing
now I'm actually going to skip forward
to talk about one final thing which is a
kind of fun for me personally because I
was wanted to help to credit push this
push this over the edge so a couple of
years ago I set a challenge for our sort
of speech and natural language and
machine translation teams that I wanted
to be able to go to China give a speech
and have it translated in real time into
Chinese I don't speak Chinese I wasn't
playing to learn in that period of time
it's pretty hard for someone at my age
and so I said hey you know I want to be
able to do that and you have all the
pieces you have speech recognition
you've got machine translation yeah
we've got text to speech we've got all
the pieces let's let's see if we can
make this work now the group dutifully
tried very hard and so two years ago a
little bit more than two years ago now
you know we went so far as they put all
the pieces together using the technology
we out at the time you know it actually
worked it worked not that badly
what when I went on stage in in
rehearsals it became really apparent to
me I couldn't really predict what the
system was going to produce right so
most of the time it did the right thing
and some fraction of the time it did
something that was vaguely vaguely
embarrassing right and and I thank the
team for working really hard and I said
you know not this time because I'm not
going to stand up on stage not knowing
exactly what's going to happen you know
in front of 3,000 Chinese students and
faculty so where you guys can work on
this a little bit more now right around
that actual same period of time there
was some interesting work going on you
know it started in in our lab and
Redmond it can continue with some of our
groups in China as well trying to
leverage a different technology for
solving the speech recognition problems
what we've been used before building on
something called deep neural networks
and what was interesting about the deep
neural networks is that unlike the the
sort of hidden Markov model techniques
that were being used before you could
feed it a lot more data and still have
it get better than the previous
techniques we've been using and there
was a public we published a paper was
actually pretty much a landmark paper
for deep neural networks published in
2009 and the we demonstrated them that
we were able to get about a thirty
percent improvement in word error rates
for for speech recognition what was
interesting about that is that for more
than ten years the word error rates for
the arbitrary speech recognition problem
had been pretty much flat and sitting at
about twenty five percent error 22 to 25
percent so this was a huge improvement
now the group continued to refine that
and work on that and so this last fall i
was making another trip to china and the
team assured me that this time they
could actually make it work and we try
I remember first trying into my office
and just being stunned by how accurate
the system was I was just talking and it
was just it was like Star Trek of the
words were just showing up on the screen
yeah how did I know what that it was
accurate uh I was looking at the English
transcription so it first does an
English transcription then a translation
and then text to speech right so i was
looking to english I figured if it
didn't have the English right I didn't
care what it is you know if it before
the English wasn't right now I could
have other people tell me whether the
Chinese was good or not so so I was
really impressed by that and basically
the I said okay let's try it you're
going to try to get so intention in late
October this year got up on stage and
had an opportunity to do this now I'm
just going to play the video this is at
the very end of the video can you guys
hear this at all I think this is working
is just that's not working either no I
know it turns off the speaker I was I'm
just trying to get it to work at all
here so and I don't know why
yep yeah it's working it's just not
picking up there's not enough sound
coming out of this I think that to make
it work so think at this point so I'm it
looks like i'm going to try let me try
something else
and apps them up to wave first new
reference or words unfortunately that
approach is extremely fragile don't just
need to get because everyone speaks I'm
just going to restart this and we'll see
if we can get it working for the
beginning
alright let's try this and yeah there we
go I I want to come back to the topic of
natural user interfaces one of the most
natural interfaces for people is human
speech and for the last 60 years
computer scientists have been trying to
find way to understand and recognize
human speech now in the beginning when
people first started tackling this
problem they looked at it largely as a
pattern matching problem you can the
early lon garrison text is attempted to
take the waveforms so that's texting out
of speakers speakers boys and match them
up two waveforms that they knew
represented certain words unfortunately
that approach is extremely fragile
partly because everyone speaks
differently but also even a single
speaker will often say the same thing
differently depending on the other words
or the context in which they're speaking
you've probably already noticed me doing
that
now in the late 1970s there was a major
change in the way that was like when I
looked up decided I realized they were
actually running the text up in the
screen the speedway agreed on was they
were going to win this was done at
Carnegie Mellon University side to do it
and the idea was to use a statistical
modeling technique in this cave hidden
Markov models to make the transition to
really be able to take a lot of data
from many speakers and produce more
robot statistical models of speech now
that was a huge improvement and over the
last 30 years speech recognition systems
have become dramatically better than
they used to be they still make a lot of
mistakes but it in limited domain it's
possible to do very successful speech
interfaces so for example in the United
States when I call my bank I'm talking
to a computer i'm not talking to a
person the computer camp answer simple
questions about my bank account or if
necessary it can connect me to a real
person if i have a significant issue
that I want to discuss I'm sure you've
heard of Apple Siri products which
answer simple questions Microsoft Kinect
has a robust speech interface that
allows you to control the interface and
even allows you to issue commands in the
middle of games
still the assistant have a lot of errors
and the error rates for arbitrary speech
have been in the twenty to twenty-five
percent around well a few years ago
researchers at Microsoft Research at the
University of Toronto came together to
develop with another breakthrough in the
field of speech recognition research the
idea that they had was to use technology
in a way patterned after the way the
human brain works it's called deep
neural networks and to use that to take
it much more data than had previously
been able to be used with the hidden
Markov model in the corner you see what
and ears down collar liking and I threw
the recognition rate it's supposed to be
serve a proxy so that when one changes
i'm going to get a breakthrough about
degrees recognition rates by
approximately thirty percent that's a
big deal that's the difference between
going from twenty to twenty-five percent
errors or about one error out of every
four or five words to roughly fifteen
percent or slightly less errors roughly
one out of every seven words or perhaps
even one out of every eight so it's
still not perfect there's still a long
way to go but I think you can see that
we have already made a significant
amount of additional progress in the
recognition of speech now one of the
problems that we've also can try to put
off my 60 years the tears for my did
this you know some of the rest the last
few years like 20 to 25 denominations of
the logistical techniques and big data
have allowed us to do a much better job
and this is all we previously we're able
to do in a pond to translate you know
certain web pages or
other kinds of information into my gosh
yeah it's a close it's a close talk
microphone for example today being
translate which is Microsoft translation
system that comes out of microsoft
research being translate translate
millions of pages a day for users into
their native language it's extremely
heavily used service now if I want to
out what I'm saying be translated into
Chinese we can take the text that comes
from my voice and put that through a
translation system it really happens in
two steps in the first instance we take
the English and we convert it more or
less word by word into into Chinese tabs
and I think pretty soon we may see that
up on the screen yeah somewhere there I
did the moon so what happens when
basically taking the English text and
pushing it to the translation system we
didn't have to reorder that text in
chinese because the word order a chinese
is not the same as the word or in
English to produce section that begins
to resemble a something that a Chinese
ed / my second as he starts an hour
taking think that was a delay in the
converting that most to dice check
waiting until you have enough
information now we worried the last step
that I want to be able to take in this
process is to actually speak to you in
Chinese now the key thing there is we've
been able to take a large amount of
information from many Chinese speakers
and produce a text-to-speech system that
takes Chinese text and converts it into
Chinese language and then we take it an
hour or so of my own voice and we've
used out to modulate the standard text
to speech system so
would sound like me so what you see now
is the result of that change I'm
speaking in English and hopefully we'll
hear me speak in Chinese in my own voice
I'm looking over to the side as I know
they're about to the audience thinks I'm
positive again the results of our
perfect there are back quite a cherry
dude walking pool unmade there's much
work to be done in this area thank you
fo yo yo Vokoun so it goes off
with this technology is very promising
film to the T short videos you love then
we hope in a few years that will be able
to break down the language barriers
between people tuned in for woman she
wasn't built out hood indonesian
personally I believe this is going to
lead to a better world to order it is
Rachel jeantel Jason father should you I
hope you enjoy the rest of the
presentations today she won't until you
see you can see how the chancel
gratifying solution
thank you so you know again from yeah it
was I don't know what that's doing there
so again from my perspective is a lot of
fun to do that obviously doing live
demos on stage in front 3,000 people are
always exciting you know the night
before when we did the rehearsal the
Frank side who's who's the one you know
behind the curtain making sure the
computer kept running and it did a lot
of work to put the demo together he he
asked me said well so if it doesn't work
does that mean I get fired I said no no
this is China your boss kiss fire the
boys the United States you'd get fired
you know but but you know I think it was
it was a lot of fun what was interesting
to me was the reaction of the audience
because the I mean literally there were
some students crying in the audience
right there was something that they've
never really expected to see you know
they were seeing it really for the first
time and and I will say you know the
certainly system is not perfect but it
did a remarkably good job we did a cat
we after the fact we did do a an
analysis of the entire transcription for
my 45 minute talk and the word error
rate was seven percent a typical word
error rate for a human in real time
would be between two and four percent so
we were doing really well you know some
of the advantage was the fact that I'm
from Iowa and evidently I speak really
well so the group really loves me to do
the demos rather than other people but
but the reality is that technology is
pretty robust and what's interesting is
actually the deep neural network
technology seems to be more robust to
noise than anything we'd use previously
noise didn't seem to really affect it
very much and the also it's interesting
is that the in terms of the the voice
data that we feed into the system it
doesn't all have to be English so we
discovered that we can feed in
Chinese French German Spanish and the
neural network for English gets better
which we think may mean that at some
point in the network what's happening is
you're really sort of modeling the human
vocal tract obviously we don't know
precisely but that seems to be possibly
what might be going on in order for that
to actually happen the advantage of this
deep neural network technology for a
number of problems of which speeches
want is particularly valuable in places
where the you don't know a good
intermediate representation right if you
have a really good intermediate
reputation for your data then more
traditional machine learning techniques
seem to work really well but when you
don't have one where speech is one
example object recognition seems to be
another example then then in fact this
technique seems to work pretty well so
with that I think because of all the
delays of the video I don't have as much
time for questions as I was hoping to
but if there are any questions I'd be
happy to answer them yeah how much
horsepower I think in to write in real
time it runs on a laptop it does take
advantage of the graphics card on the
laptop but it doesn't have to that was
just something we did it can run
perfectly well on the standard Intel
instruction set with vocals well
certainly we're so we're in the process
of getting some of this you know
obviously put into things that we may be
doing in the future you know the
question of do you want to run it on a
cell phone or do you what really want to
run it up in the cloud there's a lot of
data here right so you're working with
really large models and that's probably
the limiting factor for having it you
know running on us very small device but
certainly running on a laptop is well
within the capabilities and we you know
almost all the demos we do our one on
laptop yeah
you know the laptops were running I
think the models that were using our
several hundred megabytes they're not
gigabytes or terabytes okay yeah I have
a question so you mentioned you general
Ness as being kind of a novel way to
approach this speech problem I'm just
curious other people in this space of
googles and the Apple mysterious report
the prevailing method used these days
yeah I think since we published the
paper in 2009 what we've seen is a lot
of people have picked up on the idea and
so I mean I don't think it no one's
really try eating quite as audacious is
putting a senior corporate executive on
stage with one of these systems yeah but
but the technology is are making its way
out so you know we're already using it
in some of our being a speech
recognition work Google's using deep
neural networks now for their speech
recognition so the technologies you know
again you know from the point we publish
this and demonstrate you could get the
advantage I think we're seeing people
doing doing a lot of new work in it
what's interesting is that people are
still getting improvements I mean we're
still seeing significant improvement as
we add more data and as we refine the
techniques so we don't know where it
will wind up yet I think personally I
think that there's a reasonable chance
that we may be within you know just a
few years of effectively solving the
speech recognition problem you know at
least at the level that humans do it I
mean humans are not perfect by any
stretch of the imagination so so we're
that's that's really looking promising
right now I mean we may still hit a
barrier you don't know that you until
you do but at the moment it looks really
really good the biggest limitations
right now on the technology you might
have seen that in the video is is in the
effectively the punctuation right
finding the right spots to break
sentences and to break phrases that's
not that big a deal for a human who's
just looking at the text going by
because we've we solved that problem
really easily but for translation it's a
big problem because the translation
systems you know want to work on on
sentence or sentence fragments and sort
of want to know where the where the
boundaries are and you know if the
boundaries are wrong you know it can
cause the translation to get get messed
up yeah so one of the things I saw it
when you said error rate it used a ir
are using bottles of English the
language like a grammar checker so this
being step in this flow where it
probably could have caught that air
wasn't that error yeah so it around it
so the answer is is it's using it does
have a model of English but the you know
it's it's not it's not a grammar model
right it's just a statistical right so
so you're going to see error also their
errors in the data meaning you know we
the you get you feed in your feet in a
lot of tech these days most of our
translation system for example a name
for our transcription systems most of
the information that's being fed in is
not human curated right so it's coming
from the web you know we're not
necessarily looking at at aligned pairs
or anything of that sort and we're doing
all that statistically and so you're
going to see some errors creep into the
system because of that yeah um in
written text is a writer identification
is not quite as all problems getting
closer are you using the same thing but
it's doing the error estimation for you
is it knowing how you talk was it now
actually there was nothing so the only
part that was particular to me that was
trained on me was the text to speech
output so the texas speech output was
using my vocal characteristics no other
part of the system had any any single
user information and for the deep neural
network stuff that it actually for the
most part turns out to be so far we
haven't figure out how to get much
speaker advantage there may be ways that
we can add speak advantage into the
pipeline but i prefer work errors that's
definitely speaker you yeah it could be
but that's that there isn't it
right it's it's it part of the problem
is the amount of data that's being fed
in we don't have that much data for a
single person so in the system you saw
we now use more than that but in the
system you saw he used to use 6500 hours
of speech 22 to build the neural network
I'm not going to sit there and talk
right yeah that I can put a microphone
you would watch it for three years and I
have it sure you can right okay so
software patents are becoming
increasingly controversial what rolling
you see software patents in the future
of Microsoft Research uh roll future
Mike I don't they don't have they don't
play a role in my credit or them is you
know no we don't mean the patent is you
know there's nothing about what we do
that in any way you know is is
predicated on the pads we generated or
anything like that you know so you know
we do file pounds because you know in
our business everybody's filing patents
and you'd be stupid not to but but that
isn't we don't we don't reward
researchers particularly for patents we
don't have a you know it's not part of
our metrics you know you don't get a
bigger bonus if you have more patents
than someone else there's just nothing
about the system that works that way and
in fact actually for Microsoft as a
whole and microsoft research in
particular the number of pounds we file
is purely predicated and how much money
the corporation is willing to spend on
on prosecuting patents it's hugely
hugely expensive and so we're limited
how much money we're willing to spend I
would cut it off your shirt
you